on the campaign trail Donald Trump
boasted that no one strikes a trade deal
better than he does
and we need a truly great leader now we
need a leader that wrote the art of the
deal but after more than two and a half
years in office
Trump is negotiated only one major deal
that hasn't been approved in 2018 he
withdrew the United States from the
North American Free Trade Agreement or
NAFTA a deal to replace it known as the
u.s. MCA has been signed but has still
not been passed by the US Congress I
think if we're looking at the broader
trade uncertainty that Trump's policies
have imposed upon not just the US
economy but the global economy we have
to say that his trade policies have been
a simple disaster Trump last month
announced a deal to sell more American
beef to Europe but he's antagonized
Europeans with levees on foreign steel
and is threatening tariffs on cars at a
recent g7 meeting Trump floated the
possibility of a free trade deal with
Britain after brexit but he's offered no
specifics very very good trade off
a very big trade deal also at the recent
g7 meeting Trump announced a deal with
Japan on agriculture in e-commerce
but until signed even in Trump's words
it remains just an agreement in
principle I'm not saying they're stupid
I'd like China I believe they want to do
a deal the tariffs have hit them very
hard in a fairly short period of time
China and the United States have raised
tariffs on one another in a
back-and-forth trade dispute that
continues to escalate and threatens the
global economy so why is it so hard for
President Trump to complete a deal he's
has shown himself to be not a credible
negotiating partner and that's not how
you close deals that how that's how you
get people to walk away from the table
president Trump's record on trade has
become a political liability with fears
of a global recession investors are
nervous and US farmers hit hard by
Chinese tariffs are losing hope that's a
problem for Trump and unless resolved
could hurt his chances for re-election
Kimberley hellcat al Jazeera the White
House